und ich möchte ihnen sagen ich bin nur
noch wütend wütend darauf was mir
politiker in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten erzählt haben denn stellen sie
sich vor ich bin dreimal geimpft jetzt
sehen wir hier zwar bilder von wladimir
putin der dort möglicherweise auch über
sputnik und den impfstoff spricht aber
ich kann ihnen sagen ich rege mich vor
allem über deutsche politiker auf
stellen sie sich vor ich bin dreimal
geimpft ich habe mich mit krone
angesteckt 2020 also bin ich einmal
gelesen und was ist vor zwei wochen
passiert ich habe mich wieder mit corona
angesteckt ich bin also jetzt doppelt
genießen und dreifach geben für dich
kundenkarten oder super super super
immune unter uns aber dennoch wollen
politiker erzählt dass diese in pflicht
sein muss es geht einfach nicht anders
okay ich habe es am anfang irgendwie
noch verstanden da hat man mir erklärt
ja ja eine impfung schützt uns dann
gegen kommende ansteckung geschützt
dagegen aber als ich dann gedacht hat
mensch ich bin gelesen ich war dreifach
geimpft und jetzt habe ich mich wieder
angesteckt so frage ich wie kann das
denn passieren wie konnte das denn sein
und da gab es politiker in allen
parteien war der spd bei der cdu der
bundeskanzler der vizekanzler alle haben
mir erzählt nein nein das ist alles
schon wahnsinnig sinnvoll was wir hier
besprechen und diskutieren
die wahrheit ist doch die politiker
ändern ihre meinung in dieser frage fast
wöchentlich und das ist dieser stress
welches bild dort abgegeben wird denn
jetzt und das ist wirklich die absolute
wahnsinns aussage in dieser debatte da
erzählt man uns doch ernsthaft man müsse
sich durch die impfung für den nächsten
varianten schützen ja bitte also stellen
sie sich vor ich gelesen dreifache ihm
jetzt wieder genesen ich glaube ich
krieg bewohner noch mal und die
politiker haben wieder quatsch erzählt
wenig corona virus wäre würde ich mich
schlapp lachen wie sozusagen hier ein
land über jahre und seine politiker über
monate und monate zu unsinnigsten dingen
verleiten kann ich glaube aber dass
diese emotionale hätte womöglich einen
totalen wendepunkt auslöst in der
politik denn ab sofort muss an fünf
gelten nur wer zwei mal genießen drei
mal geimpft ist kann künftig noch im
fernsehstudio ich muss dann leider
also es ist es ist tatsächlich verrückt
und wer selber was tragisch was ja und
wenn gras ja gar nicht so also einer
stichwahl die ich war von anfang an sind
eine hilfe noch immer nicht genau ich es
wagen mich und ich schließe dich
verloren hat paramus man muss schon
sagen jetzt ohne dass ich die einzelnen
verläufe alle bis ins detail kennen aber
nicht ganz einfach
da war ein bisschen so dass er 20 20
fühlte ich mich doch da habe ich mir
noch diese sauerstoffgerät geholt und
machen ist das jetzt schlimm oder aber
und jetzt war es so ich habe noch nutzen
sie hat ein bisschen kopfüber quarantäne
quarantäne sie dürfen nicht aus und
gefährden die menschheit aber das liegt
vielleicht auch daran dass sie dann ging
waren so weil man ja weiß wenn man
geimpft ist dann hat man aber
jetzt wegen weg sind ja immer die logik
dahinter die logik also ich persönlich
wechsel die gar nicht weil ich sagt wenn
wir eine höhere info.de haben dann haben
wir genau solche verläufe vielleicht
häufiger wie bei ihnen wenn wir keine
geringe impfquote haben dann haben wir
viel mehr menschen die auf den
intensivstationen landen und dann ja all
die folgeprobleme über die wir
gesprochen haben belastung der
intensivstation
war aber schon anders also ich bin jetzt
wirklich kein wahnsinniger iwes kirchen
aber als ich mich zum ersten mal impfen
lassen war die erzählung wenn man sich
im pool ist kriegt man es nicht mehr
stimmt also war die heute ist ja nicht
wenig
und natürlich habe ich habe ich daran
auch geglaubt ich könnte sogar sagen
vertraut und jetzt bin ich jetzt auch in
der arbeit werden würde haben da will
ich ihnen ja gar nicht wieder springen
also wenn sie wenn sie sich aussagen
anschauen vom märz 2020 vom herbst 2020
natürlich sind die zum großteil überholt
und meine hoffnung war auch ich kann
auch sagen vom halben jahr hätte ich
gesagt okay nach der zweiten impfung
sind wir wahrscheinlich alle übern berg
brauchen gar nicht ein booster impfung
der wussten wert auch gar nicht in
deutschland was boostern ist bis auf
ganz wenige ausnahmen und hatten wir das
so gut dann leben wir wieder normal nur
das ist ja nicht so dass ich jetzt hier
sitze und paar andere im bundestag die
sagen wir ändern mal das virus damit wir
diese debatte weiterführen das sind ja
einfach mutationen
ihre eigentlichen ziele die viele andere
länder die viele andere länder auch
gerade erleben deswegen haben wir ja
eine impfpflicht in italien eingeführt
deswegen gibt es diese sie haben sich an
initiativen
deswegen gibt es in der impfpflicht in
italien eingeführt wurde deswegen hat er
mal crowe in frankreich gar nicht das
ist ja nicht so ist wie hier losgelöst
von der welt wären war nun mal klar und
italien das ist ja noch
andere hinterland darauf reagiert
fahrwerk nicht wir alle die hier in der
runde sitzen beschäftigen sich ja jeden
tag eigentlich mit dem thema corona wir
lesen zeitungen wir schauen tv
was glauben sie was denken die menschen
die nicht so viel mit medien und politik
zu tun haben über das was ihnen da dann
hin und wieder von den politikern in
sachen corona erklärt wird ich glaube
ich schon immer mehr menschen auf das
sich das oft widerspricht also das oft
dinge erzählt werden und später so unter
der hand die gleiche maßnahme ist mit
anderen begründungen versehen wird oder
gar nichts mehr begründet wird also zb
als man jetzt den genesenen status über
nacht auf drei monate verringert hat als
einziges land also alle anderen länder
eu weit sind es sechs monate im
bundestag nimmt bis sechs monate aber
ansonsten für alle normalsterblichen
wohnung 3 da wurde ja noch nicht mal
eine begründung mitgeliefert und ich
glaube dass viele leute einfach nur den
kopf schütteln ich meine natürlich ist
man als laie in dieser frage auch immer
so ein bisschen
ausgeliefert also ich bin ich bin ja nur
weil ich auch nicht von meiner kompetenz
her irgendwie virologen oder medizinerin
ich bin ökonomen also das heißt ich habe
auch dadurch dass ich relativ viel
gelesen habe versucht mir überhaupt eine
meinung zu bilden und wenn man sich um
tut dann findet man ja auch verschiedene
meinungen von biologen also nicht immer
nur die die hauptsächlich von der
regierung befragt werden und dann kann
man vielleicht auch eine differenzierte
sicht entwickeln aber ich merke ja wie
viel zeit das braucht und wenn man jetzt
jeden tag also acht stunden oder
vielleicht sogar noch ein zweiter hat
also arbeitet und familie und so wer hat
denn diese zeit das heißt man merkt nur
irgendwie und ich glaube das merken
schon viele dass ich das widerspricht
was die politik erzählt dass einige
politiker zu ende immer den den alarm
modus an haben also immer das
schlimmstmögliche profitieren also unser
gesundheitsminister ist da ein
spezialfall und natürlich manchmal tritt
das schlimmer auch ein auftritt es zum
glück nicht ein aber ich finde es ist
eben auch schlechte politik immer den
leuten angst einzureden so kann man so
macht man ja auch das ganze
gesellschaftliche klima kaputt wenn
leute immer angst haben dann verhalten
sie sich ja irgendwie komisch das ist
echt ein problem in frankreich es gibt
ja eine spannende analyse dieser
angstmacherei klaus die hat ja sehr sehr
gut funktioniert aus politischer sicht
muss man sagen wir markus söder der vom
jumbojet gesprochen hat der abt 4 und
tod 400 euro und der essent wert nach
oben liga und diejenigen die eher
vorsichtig waren und auch ausgleichen
und wie zum beispiel armin laschet der
hat wahnsinnig verloren also oder karl
lauterbach zum beispiel dass auch gutes
beispiel dafür der ja auch eher
alarmistisch war und in den
beliebtheitswerten auf platz eins ist
also sind wir hier die
minderheitsmeinung das kann vielleicht
sogar sein aber ich bin merke schon eine
starke drehung also die werte von markus
söder sind jetzt nicht mehr die
allerbesten karl lauterbach handelt sich
jetzt im amt wo er nicht mehr sagen kann
wie man es richtig machen muss sondern
wie man es richtig machen muss
selber machen muss handelt sich glaube
ich viel viel viel kritik ein ich will
auch einmal bei aller anekdotischen
zuspitzung sagen das ist schon schwierig
den richtigen kurs zu finden aber angst
und panik verbreiten da bin ich ganz bei
vor wagenknecht ist für politiker das
allerletzte was sie anstreben und es
gibt ja übrigens bei der kampagne fürs
impfen da gibt es ein wunderbares
beispiel aus frankreich dabei gibt es
eine tolle kampagne wo sozusagen die
läuft auf den gedanken raus menschen das
sieht wahnsinnig sympathische leute wie
sie sich umarmen wie sie sich küssen und
dann ist etwa so der gedankengang wenn
wir uns alle impfen lassen dann können
wir bald diese szenen wieder erleben und
da hab ich mir überlegt wie werden
kampagne wohl in deutschland und die
kampagne in deutschland wer küssen
bringt tod und deshalb im und das ist
sozusagen das exakte unterschied ich
glaube dass menschen extrem positiven
sinne sind für ba durch positive
emotionen durch klar machen warum es gut
ist etwas zu tun und nicht durch wenn du
jetzt das nicht machen müssen wir alle
sterben und ich habe ja das führt jetzt
ein bisschen weg keine sorge bin gleich
wieder da ich habe ja die angst dass
diese methode angst machen um ein ziel
zu erreichen am ende der code ist den
politiker aus dieser krise mitnehmen
also abends nach 22 uhr nicht mehr auto
fahren sonst müssen wir alle sterben
wegen der umwelt ja jetzt lachen alle
ich hätte aber auch nicht gedacht dass
man seinen hund nicht mehr ausführen
darf nur weil ein bisschen corona ist
also insofern das ist das was man
erstmal deswegen ist mein punkt die
schlimmste longo wird folge ist nicht
dass man ein bisschen länger braucht bis
man wieder marathon laufen kann sondern
die schlimmste longo wird folge ist dass
diese demokratie eine delle bekommt die
man lange nicht mehr wächst das darf in
der tat nicht sein also dass wir es gibt
ja einige auch bei der grünen jugend die
jetzt schon ankommen und sagen es muss
danach weitere freiheitseinschränkung
geben mit der begründung ist wichtig für
das klima da sind wir völlig einer
meinung das darf nicht passieren und
klimas wegen ist ja meine wohnung ist ja
auch eine positive also ich versuche ja
ein positives bild zu schaffen und sie
haben auch sie haben auch einen
richtigen punkt gemacht wenn man sich
mal die werbekampagnen anschaut fürs
impfen in frankreich küssen der menschen
eine tolles foto in deutschland
irgendwie eine kampagne die er darin
erinnert als ob nie
langweilig geworden langweiliges
schnarcht